[Music]
for Donald Trump's most entrenched
supporters this is simply another cause
to Rally around
he calls it a politically motivated
Witch Hunt and they believe him they're
so frightened of him they don't know
what to do
this is a watershed moment but perhaps
the most remarkable fact is that this is
not even the most serious of the
potential criminal charges that Donald
Trump May face
legal Jeopardy abounds for the former
president not least over an FBI
investigation and raid of his Mar-A-Lago
home officers finding top secret
documents here that had disappeared with
Trump from the White House
a probe is ongoing too into whether he
interfered with a 2020 election count in
Georgia we fight like hell and if you
don't fight like hell you're not going
to have a country anymore
and perhaps most grave of all the
allegation that he incited violence
leading to the January the sixth
storming of the capital I'd say he's in
a mess he's in a heap of trouble some
experts believe this indictment could
prompt charges in other cases now he has
got the label of a criminal defendant in
a in an ongoing prosecution so it may
not be the crime of the century but it
does go to the heart and essence of what
many think he is a fraudster and so once
you get charged the first time I think
it's probably easier on the system
itself
to get charged again
but Trump's legal problems May
conversely be giving him a political
boost polls show his support among
Republican voters is surging the charges
facing Donald Trump do not dissuade
Republican primary voters at all they
rallied some of them to his cause
there's a very small sliver of the
Republican party that views Trump as
problematic or is troubled by these
charges but they already weren't
supporting Donald Trump anyway so it's
really irrelevant
team Trump says he's raised over seven
million dollars in campaign donations in
the five days since his indictment
became public knowledge proved perhaps
that in Trump's world even criminal
charges can be given a positive spin
Martha Kellner Sky News West Palm Beach